we've already looked at this in Reverse
okay we've looked at if you have a
fraction or a percentage okay for
instance suppose you wanted to have
three quarters okay and they give you a
quantity they give you a quantity three
quarters or if you wanted to know three
quarters of seventy two Donuts right
this is a typical question um they give
you the fraction and then they give you
the quantity and then you have to
calculate I don't know I've got that off
part right we translate that
mathematically into our multiplication
that's right so we'd say 3/4 72 okay
now I'm aware that you can get your
calculator out and you could do this but
surely the numbers are small enough that
we don't have to can we do if I do this
in a heads what could we do yes Ashley
okay now like we can do it two times
three car week it would be two hundred
and sixteen now I can do that but
there's a quicker way is it there any
suggestions helium okay good so that
three times 32 is the right way to go
it's not a wrong thing to do but it does
make numbers big and my brain doesn't
like big numbers I like small numbers
okay so therefore instead of multiplying
and making things bigger first I'm going
to divide first that makes things small
arms with it now does anyone know what
72 divided by four years years out 1818
now in case you couldn't do that in your
head like me you so stared at it for a
little while and thought hmm
I think it divides through you can do a
couple of intermediate steps to make it
easier for you for instance we look at
canceling before right cancelling okay
so for smb2 we know something's going to
cancel in there maybe you don't know how
to divide this straight by force all you
can do is do something smaller pick a
small on a buck like seat to choose a
common factor between them right so if I
divided 72 by 2 where a bit better than
that are better than no we know how to
do that that's gonna be 230 seats isn't
it you know we know that number
so you take you up there and then you do
it again you get 18 okay
just like Rashad [ __ ] alright 3 times 18
we can do 3 times 18
someone has it's anything yet how are
you could do 3 times come on brain wake
up you can do it
54 wait was that was that how was that
no one good until okay there you go
54 doughnuts there you go that's fine
now what we going to do now is the same
I did one in Reverse okay so so instead
of being given a fraction and a total
quantity okay a fraction in the total
budget what we're going to do is have
two quantities and work out the fraction
okay example let's do mmm
if I told you okay you don't get 54
Donuts tough you know I'm not feeling
that yesterday but I'm still gonna give
you a doughnut which is more than one
for everyone I could give you zero
Donuts okay so I'm gonna do baby Donuts
add off sub you two days okay now we're
going to do this as a fraction and as a
percentage okay and then we'll talk
about a little bit about why that might
be useful when you saw three quarters of
72 you said x which is correct okay
but now I've got 30 not of I've got 30
out of 30 - so what should I write
mathematically it's there mm-hmm
yeah okay good so that takes us to 30
over seven - that's division that's the
opposite so be very careful with the
language them okay now here I can do
some simplifying kana what can I
simplify yeah
you say ah Rand awakener came out my
brain yeah
what numbers can I cancel here in order
to simplify this fraction
yeah Jasmine you can take out two buddy
got two I get 15 then and then I would
get 36 okay I can keep going Connaught
what can I take out now yeah I know Oh
three three three I can do three so I
would get five yeah and I would get well
twelve here what's the highest common
factor of 5 and 12 it's just it's just
one is it
finebros now song as you have noticed we
could have gone straight from 30 to 5
and 7 to 12 by dividing by 6 that were
done okay
but it's fun it's still the same thing 5
over 12